اذا
نتابع لان كلمه لنائبه الرئيس الامريكي
اشكر القاده هنا لنقاشاتهم المستمره في
هذا الخصوص
والعدد الموضع الاخرى واشكركم لانضمامكم
الينا اليوم لك الكلمه السيد رئيس الوزراء
رئيس
لهذا الاجتماع
ام بي سي
بالستين اليابان
الو
فقط اطلقت اكثر من 50 صاروخا بالستين
بنسبه غير مسبوقه
وكما اطلق الصاروخان اليوم وهذا غير مقبول
اطلاقا
واليوم مع حضرنا هنا
اود ان اعبر عن ارادتنا جميعا
اشد العبارات
دوري دوري
الشماليه ستطلق المزيد من الصواريخ او حتى
الاختبارات النوويه
لقرار مجلس الامن فان المجتمع الدولي يجب
ان يستجيب بشكل موحد
كلام
بين اليابان وكوريا الشماليه هناك مساء
الاخرى اود ان تهز هذه الفرصه
لطلبي للدعم القوي المستمر من كافه الدول
الحاضره هنا
شكرا شكرا
هذا استفزاز صاروخ
الى جانب الصواريخ السابقه فهذا يعبر
انتهاك واضح العديد من القرارات مجلس
الامن
وتهديد كبير للسلامه والاستقرار في شبه
الجزيره الكوريه ومنطقتي اسيا والعالم
يجمع نحن نريد
ان يركز على انه مثل هذه القانونيه من قبل
كوريا الشماليه لن نتقبل لها ابدا
والمجتمع الدولي يجب ان يتوحده ويستجيب
بشكل حازم من خلاله ذلك
كي يجب ان يجعل
يدرك بان كل جوله من الاستفزازات سوف
تستمر بتقويهمنهم وتعقم
طيب في كان عندك
وتؤثر بشكل اكبر على شعبهم لحوث مره اخرى
كوريا الشماليه
للوقف الفوري لكافه اشكال الاستفزازات وان
تلتزم
بقرارات مجلس الامن ذات الصلح
شكرا
كندا تنضم الى حلفائنا في جانبيه شد
العبارات
الشماليه مع اطلاق العديد من الصواريخ
واخرها ليوم كما قال اصدقائنا سارق
لقرارات مجلس الامن
ويجب ان
تجدها كافه الدول العالم
على فكره
في العمليات العسكريه المشتركه في المنطقه
اللي تطبيق
عقوبات مجلس الامن واحنا نبقى او ملتزمون
اللي كافه حلفائنا في المنطقه
لضمان
توقف كوريا الشماليه عن التهديداتها غير
المسؤوله ليس فقط للاستقرار والسلام على
الاقليمي
بدنا
ناس شكرا
وهذا الا تصعيد المستمر مع الاستخدام
للصواريخ
ولكم عن تطمئنه بيننا
ساهمنا في تطبيق العقوبات ضد كوريا
الشماليه وسوف نستمر بفعل ذلك
وسوف نستمر المطالبه
الالتزام بقرارات مجلس الامن
الاطلاق الصواريخ
عشان ايه خلصت
انتشار الاسلحه النوويه نحن امه تدافع عن
مبادئ منعي الاسلحه النوويه وليس فقط
انتشارها
شكرا
متهوره
نحن قلقون جدا خاصه على الشعبيه يكون
الجنوبيه واليابان اه مره اخرى هنا الكيس
استفزاز اخر من كوريا الشماليه وهو انتهاك
واضح
لقرارات مجلس الامن والامم المتحده نحن
نقيفه مع العالم وبلا شكوى حلفائنات في
معارضه واجانه هذه تصرفات باقوى العبارات
ونطالب قريه الشماليه لوقفي هذه النشاطات
المتهوره وهذه الاستفزازات
الامم المتحده ونحن مستعدون لان نكون ضمن
استجابه دوليه لذلك
اشكر القاده هنا سوف نستمر بحواراتنا
وسيقول لاجتماع مغلقا
اذا كان هذا اجتماع عنا طاريا على هامشي
قيمته حول ازمه الصواريخ التي تطلقها
كوريا الشماليه